c'est un mur à gauche que les enfants de
cilaos et du chaudron ont en commun
raison pour laquelle six classes soit
140 enfants se rassemblent autour de
leur sport
même si certains n'avaient jamais vu si
l'un avec les trois chiens
des piton des neiges c'est tout ça que
la masse à genève tu connais il faudra
rien du tout qu'est-ce que tu que de
tilos balle et aura beau toit au
chaudron ya toi ah oui oui c'est
salutaire
c'est la fusion
découvrir de nouvelles sensations seront
fronton va souvent utilisés faute de
moyens ce jour là l'entraîneur de
l'équipe de france organise la séance
ont fait leur banc en la frappe
on l'arrêté c'est d'abord beaucoup de
motricité aux gamins la motricité avec
général pak par rapport à l'europe
on voit même un sport qui est
complètement différent mais qui pourrait
enfin most of gaming centre ouest
puisque dans les cirques tous ceux qui
jonglent mais on travaille sur la
motricité de la droite de la gauche de
montoussé du serment pour ses membres
parce qu'on doit suivre un mouvement de
travailler le haut le bas et je pense
que ça va ça le ramène pour tous les
sports on apprend aux champions je vis
de ses offres l'habitat silence je fais
la rayonnante de trois ans laissez moi
un peu de temps
le week-end il va venir jouer avec jolie
trouver la paix
un moment qui se clôture par un match
d'exhibition le top du niveau mondial
une balle qui s'écrase contre le mur
l'engagement des joueurs tout
impressionne les enfants même si cela
nécessite parfois des explications des
enseignants oui ça fait du bien ça donne
un exemple pour les jeunes ça peut leur
donner un sens aussi aux gamins qui des
fois voilà arrivé à un certain âge
notamment près de l'adolescence mais
savent pas vers quel chemin aller le le
chemin du haut niveau c'est quelque
chose de très exigeant mais c'est
certain ils retrouvent leur trouvent
leur compte
à peine le mur libérer les quelque
pelotaris sts de cilaos reprennent
possession du lieu
il n'a pas de club piscine kouriles et
la club n'avait mellal affirmé
qu'elle avait passé toujours d'accord
mais comment se trouve là j'ai retrouvé
la démonstration ce matin bien donner
une nouvelle dynamique encourager les
cilaosiens ce développement des os est
accompagné par le département
ce jour là les organisateurs ont offert
le matériel aux enseignants afin de
poursuivre l'action